skimming across the Black Sea homing in
on Russian warships this video purports
to show part of an attack that Russia
says Ukraine carried out with marine and
aerial drones in the Crimean Port of
sevastopol it says one of its
mind-sweeping vessels was lightly hit
some as yet unverified reports suggest
more damage was done more targets struck
the attack involved nine unmanned aerial
vehicles and seven autonomous Marine
drones because of the measures taken by
the Black Sea Fleet ships all the aerial
targets were destroyed Russia's defense
Ministry says British forces helped plan
the attack and were behind last month's
sabotage of its nordstream 1 and 2
pipelines Britain says these are false
claims on an epic scale the initial
response from the Kremlin to suspend its
participation in the Black Sea grain
initiative under which Ukraine has since
August been able to export more than 9
million tons of agricultural produce
through a maritime Corridor brokered by
the in Turkey
Russia has for some weeks been signaling
its displeasure with how the deal had
been playing out saying the planned
freeing up of its own exports
particularly fertilizers had not been
honored before the events in Crimea on
Saturday it had said that any
investigation by the United Nations into
its use of Iranian drones might prompt
it to exit the agreement
Ukraine's president is calling for a
strong response from the United Nations
and the g20s
Russia does everything so that millions
of people living in Africa the middle
east and south Asia will find themselves
in the condition of artificial hunger or
at the very least in a drastic price
crisis why should a small bunch of
people in the Kremlin decide whether
there will be food on people's tables in
Egypt or Bangladesh Russia says recent
Ukrainian exports were heading for rich
countries and that it is prepared to
donate 500 000 tons of grain over four
months to poor ones It also says it can
no longer guarantee the safety of
Civilian shipping along Ukraine's Black
Sea Coast Harry Fawcett Al Jazeera Kiev